[Music]
could there be
an even better planet for us than earth
scientists are searching for a super
habitable world that
wouldn't just rival earth but be a place
where life
could thrive even more easily and
they're looking at exoplanets how would
we discover
earth 2.0 what would make
an exoplanet habitable
and how long would it take to get there
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we discovered
earth 2.0 you wouldn't be able to find
an
exoplanet by looking through a telescope
all you'd see is the bright glare of the
stars they orbit
nasa built the kepler telescope to
discover exoplanets
and before it ran out of fuel the kepler
telescope
surveyed our region of the milky way
galaxy
its technology uses the transit method
to find planets hundreds of light years
away
how it measured the fluctuation of light
coming from distant stars when a planet
transits or passes in front of a star
the star isn't as bright so the kepler
telescope
uses that to detect exoplanets
this is not an easy thing to do but
during its 9-year lifetime
the kepler telescope confirmed the
existence
of 4 36 exoplanets
could any of them be earth 2.0
if you're a long time fan of what if
you've probably heard this before but
earth is a very special place
and even if a planet is deemed
to be habitable it doesn't mean that it
resembles
earth very much a habitable planet is
a rocky planet located in the habitable
zone
allowing water to stay on the planet's
surface in its liquid form
that's it venus and mars are
habitable planets but they are
definitely
not like earth so let's talk about
three major conditions that we'd look
for when searching for
an even better version of earth
first it would need to have sunlight
our sun's lifespan is about 10 billion
years and it took 4 billion years for
anything more complex than the simplest
life form to
pop up on our planet but k-type
dwarf stars have lifespans of about
70 billion years so if we found an
exoplanet orbiting a k-type star
there would be more time for life to
evolve and live on it
the second major condition is
temperature
a planet that's too hot or too cold
wouldn't be able to host
the life forms we'd need to survive but
if we find a planet that's a mere five
degrees warmer than earth
and it has more water we could be
looking at earth 2.0
covered in a lush biodiverse rainforest
the third major condition we'd be
looking for is size
gravity retains a planet's atmosphere
and there's a direct relationship
between
gravity and a planet's size so
if we find a planet that's only one and
a half times larger than earth
it would be able to hold on to its
interior heat and
maintain its atmosphere for a longer
time
but bigger isn't always better
while earth-sized exoplanets are usually
rocky
about 50 percent of the exoplanets
larger than earth
are gas giants and if an exoplanet is
too small
it would likely be barren like mars
so are there any exoplanets out there
that meet these requirements
you know all this comparing data and
gathering information is
starting to make my head hurt i wish i
could just enter everything into one
piece of software and
we could see which exoplanet could be
earth 2.0
instead i have to sift through
spreadsheets and confusing software
if you run a business then you know my
pain but luckily for you
there are solutions like netsuite you
could stop paying for multiple systems
that
don't give you the information you need
when you need it and
you can ditch the spreadsheets there's
no better time to upgrade to netsuite by
oracle the world's number one cloud
business system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials
hr inventory e-commerce and more
it's everything you need all in one
place and it doesn't matter how much
revenue you're making
a million 100 million you could be
saving time
and money with netsuite join the 24
000 plus companies using netsuite right
now
if only there was a netsuite for
exoplanet discovery
so while i'm stuck doing this you should
let netsuite show you how they'll
benefit your business
with a free product tour at netsuite.com
what if
schedule your free product tour right
now at netsuite.com
what if that's netsuite.com what if
okay i found a planet that could be
super habitable
kepler-1649c could be a contender to
become
earth 2.0 it's 300 light years away and
orbits a red dwarf star
it gets sunlight but only 75
as much as earth so it might be a bit
cooler there
and there wouldn't be any seasons on
kepler's 1649c
a full orbit only takes 19 and a half
earth days so
we'd need to get used to that oh and it
could be
tidally locked which means one side of
the planet
constantly faces its sun while the other
side
faces space also
living on a planet that orbits a red
dwarf star
could be risky sometimes red dwarf stars
send out massive flares dousing an
orbiting planet in uv light and
creating huge temperature fluctuations
but if we decide that kepler 1649c
is worthy of becoming earth 2.0
what would happen next well
using our current technology it would
take at least
2 000 years to reach this earth 2.0
and since this planet is so far away
we only know about its size the distance
to its star
and the makeup of its atmosphere
so we could pack up humanity
take the multi-generational trip to
earth 2.0
and discover that it's more like a
neptune
2.0 yeah there's no way we could survive
on a gas
giant we need much more information
before we send
humans to any possible earth 2.0s
so right now nasa is developing a tiny
probe
to travel at one-fifth of the speed of
light
it could greatly expand our knowledge of
exoplanets
and we shouldn't limit ourselves to
looking just at exoplanets
a moon receives direct solar energy from
its star and
the planet it orbits reflects solar
energy toward it so
maybe a moon could be more suitable for
human life
than an exoplanet the most earth-like
planet in
our solar system is titan saturn's
largest moon
so if we want to save thousands of years
of traveling
maybe titan could make a good second
home for us
what would life be like on titan
well the seasons would be really really
long for one thing but
i'm getting ahead of myself because
that's a story
for another what if